bonsoir thierry clair merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france auditions
de gérald darmanin hier aujourd'hui
c'était le patron de la police et un
soutien de votre hiérarchie à la hauteur
de vos attentes
écoutez en tout cas c'est un discours
qui va dans le sens des moyens qui sont
demandés qui sont attendus par les
policiers faut savoir qu'elle ne moral
des troupes n'est pas très long
aujourd'hui on a eu des jours difficiles
qui se sont passées une police qui s'est
sentie et des policiers qui se sont
sentis stigmatisés par une affaire sur
lequel on a fait beaucoup d'amalgamés en
fait on a tenté de faire le procès de la
police
et voilà donc il faut prendre en compte
effectivement ces considérations il faut
prendre en compte aussi qu'on a des
collègues qui seront été véritablement
violentée lors des manifestations samedi
en fin d'après-midi s'est traduit
d'ailleurs pas véritablement par des
lynchages de deux policiers
certains qui ont perdu des dents
d'ailleurs voilà donc c'est les réalités
du moment et je pense qu'il ya
effectivement des annonces en tout cas
de soutien qui sont attendus qui était
attendu qui sont attendus mais également
qui se traduise ensuite par des moyens
il faut qu'on arrête systématiquement
chaque fois qu'il y ait qu il y a des
des manquements qui peut l'être ou des
diffusion d'image qu'on fasse le procès
de la police des manquements il y en a
eu il y en aura quoi qu'il en soit ce
sont des moments qui sont marginaux donc
à des interventions de police il ya plus
3 millions d'interventions de police
quotidiennement donc c'est vrai que l'on
ne peut pas faire le procès de la police
systématiquement c'est le moral des
troupes qu'on atteint c'est le service
public de la police quand on atteint
c'est le rapport aussi entre la police
et la population
s'il ya des manquements et quand il ya
des manquements et quand il ya notamment
des images qui sont diffusées de toute
façon des procédures sont mises en place
que ce soit des procédures judiciaires
des procédures administratives
il s'agit pas de condamner les
fonctionnaires qui ont commis des
manquements est ce qu'il s'agit de deux
paires de sang froid de leurs parce que
ce sont des gens qui n'ont pas leur
place chez nous c'est assez lent qu'elle
qui le dira en globalité en tout cas ce
sont les décisions judiciaires
administratives dès lors qu'elles ne
sont pas prises en dha sous la pression
médiatique
le déterminant c'est vrai que ces images
de la faire avec l'arrêt clair en tout
cas été vous l'admettrez peut-être sans
doute absolument dévastatrice
dans ce contexte certains dit frédéric
veaux heureusement très peu nombreux
mais malheureusement encore trop
nombreux ces gars en commettant des
actes contraires à la loi et au code de
déontologie
vous partagez tout de même ce constat
quelle a été votre réaction quand vous
avez justement vous aussi découvert ces
images nous on n'a jamais mis le
couvercle sur les affaires et je dirais
les policiers n'ont qu on est tout à
fait conscient effectivement qu'il peut
y avoir des dérapages de débordements et
il y en a eu il y en a et il y en aura
forcément le tour en fait c'est de
retrouver de la sérénité dans le travail
de prendre en considération que les
policiers fort métier difficile ils sont
confrontés à la violence quotidiennement
que d'ailleurs le nombre de policiers
blessés
il ya eu un article de presse la semaine
dernière ont été doublé en l'espace de
ces dix dernières années ça c'est une
réalité qu'il faut qu'il faut prendre en
considération
c'est un cercle vicieux la violence qui
appelle la violence des deux côtés non
mais les policiers doivent s'adapter
c'est pour ça que le métier est
compliqué et qu'il est difficile non
seulement il est dangereux parce qu'on à
faire à toutes sortes de personnes on va
le faire bien sûr démission d'ed
d'assistance sur des individus qui sont
relativement dangereux sur d'autres dont
on doit déterminer effectivement
l'éventuelle dangerosité ou pas c'est
toute la complexité du métier on doit
faire notre assurer notre profession
notre service public en tout cas de
police dans ces conditions là et c'est
vrai que il y a aussi des lacunes dans
notre dans notre corporation et
notamment d'ailleurs le ministre a en
effet en ce qui concerne virelles à la
formation continue la formation continue
dans les rangs de notre institution qui
est totalement insuffisante qui
n'existent quasiment pas hormis les
trois tirs réglementaire annuelle
la formation ne concerne très peu de
fonctionnaires et souvent quand elle est
mise en vente en place c'est souvent
d'ailleurs une contrainte pour les
policiers parce que le travail en flux
tendu tout le monde d'ailleurs ne peut
pas y participer et souvent ça se
traduit par des décalages horaires donc
oui il faudrait véritablement il ya des
choses à moderniser
il faut que la formation continue et
s'inscrivent dans un parcours
professionnel
le premier policier bref que l'on
modernise la police oui qu'on ne fasse
pas son procès systématiquement dès lors
qu'il ya des affaires qui a des
manquements ou des abus c'est vrai que
gérald darmanin évoqué la formation
aussi l'équipement de la police il a
aussi évoqué
le problème de l'encadrement pas assez
de chefs et de son chef
sur le terrain ce que vous partagez vous
aussi ce constat c'est vrai que les on
le voit dans certaines grandes
circonscriptions en région parisienne
notamment deux jeunes policiers qui sont
d'ailleurs pour certains même pas
titulariser qui seront se retrouve
quelques fois deux en patrouille qui
sont confrontées justement assurer les
missions du service public police et qui
n'ont pas d'encadrement c'est vrai qu'il
ya il faut remettre
il faut mettre je dirais et prévoir des
postes d'encadrement tout cas sur le
terrain sur la voie publique
effectivement il y à il ya ce besoin il
ya cette nécessité
il faut qu'il ya un travail collectif en
fait qu'ils soient faits par tous je
veux dire tout corps tous grades le tout
le monde doit assumer ses
responsabilités je dirais être aux côtés
en tout cas des collègues des jeunes
collègues notamment qui sont confrontés
à mettre en application en fait ce qu'on
aura appris en théorie à l'école à
l'école de police mais je veux dire
confronter la réalité des choses
changent complètement et si vous n'avez
pas des fonctionnaires aguerris autour
de vous s'il n'avait pas un encadrement
en tout cas qui vous permet de deux de
dire comment est ce qu'on doit
appréhender les choses comment est ce
qu'on doit faire comment est-ce qu'on
doit pratiquer dans le cadre de nos
missions
effectivement c'est bien ça devient
compliqué à propos de terrain gérald
darmanin annoncé la généralisation des
caméras piétons à partir de juillet
frédéric veaux elle a appelé de ses
voeux un port pour vous les policiers
déjà pourra-t-on les généraliser pardon
ça ne marche pas très bien
en france nous avons des caméras piétons
mais qui sont totalement inopérant
inopérante qui ne fonctionne pas
d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas utilisés par
les policiers parce que la charge de
batterie totalement insuffisantes
il ya des problèmes techniques pour la
fixation sur les tenues enfin bref tout
où la très bien pour qu'on ne les
utilisent pas il ya des appels en tout
cas de nouveaux marchés qui a été lancé
les caméras piétons les policiers sont
favorables on n'a rien à cacher quand on
est policier quand on est au moins je
dirais que ça permet de contextualiser
l'émission est en tout cas par le son et
par l'image parce que c'est vrai que la
nuit la parole du policier elle vaut pas
grand chose aujourd'hui il est très
souvent remise en cause et c'est vrai
que moi avec la caméra piétons ça sera
quelque part une protection pour les
policiers mais aussi à condition d'avoir
du matériel qu'ils soient opérons facile
à utiliser et
et qui sert avant tout cas qui sert
l'ensemble de nos collègues
merci thierry clair d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france